reverse engineering an alien or a craft
that is not made by human hands not by
not by man not of this world and says
well I want in they're like no you're
not coming in he says well you're wrong
they show him a list known as the bigot
list b g t deres from World War II
doesn't mean bigotry it means something
totally different and that's the list of
who's in and who's out or who's in and
it's roughly 500 people and he notices
they're all corporate contractors almost
none of them are DOD
people and and he says well I need in
and they're like no you're not coming in
well what are your criteria well we
don't have to tell you our criteria
except you're not in well I'm going to
go complain they said Be Our Guest
complain see see what we'll see if we
care